everyone knows that a bull can
take your life but I don't think if I
think the opposite of me a bull
gives it to me
today
[Music]
my name is josé manuel medina and I'm
cut off
the cut is lucky to put you in
front  from the face of the bull get rid of
him without getting caught
the differences between the world
of trimming and bullfighting because
in
plain view we go out to face the
bulls without any help or crutch
or sword or anything either
no harm is done to the bull it is a one-on-one
fight in the world of trimming there are three
types of luck luck is scored from
0 to 10 and well the judges decree that
the score is the cut or the jump or
the jog  It's good because the score
will be higher
for me and I see it as an enemy and I
see it more as a friend.
there from my town of areva  it
with little heifers and such
I said when I started in this world that
when I was a father I would stop
cutting but in the end I have been a father and
I am unable to be able to leave it
myself the truth is that when I am in
front of the bulls the only thing I feel
It is an immense joy, the happiness that
comes to me to be in front of the face of
this beautiful animal
when a time comes to retire or
to leave this because I believe that the one
who is born the trimmer never dies of
cutters
that's how it is
[Music]